So this is really interesting.
Donald Trump tweeted about the Confederate
flag in the context of NASCAR, and it became
a really big topic at yesterday's press briefing
with Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley
McEnany.
So just to refresh refresh you a little bit
on these press briefings, they start very
late.
They are very, very short.
Few questions are taken and they almost always
end with a scripted walk off line from Kaley
McEnany.
They want these to be sort of like Mike drop
moments.
The Trump trumps love them.
I cringe when I see them.
And yesterday, the topic of Donald Trump's
tweet about.
The Confederate flag was a big topic of conversation.
Just to refresh the tweet once again, Trump
tweeting yesterday has Bubba Wallace apologize
to all of those great NASCAR drivers and officials
who came to his aid, stood by his side and
were willing to sacrifice everything for him,
only to find out that the whole thing was
just another hoax.
That and flag decision has caused the lowest
ratings ever.
So as a result of the tweet, a bunch of questions
yesterday about this.
Trump want the Confederate flag in more places?
Is Trump supporting the Confederate flag?
And Kaylee McInerney kept repeating, Trump
isn't making a judgment one way or the other
about the flag.
Which, of course, is exactly the problem.
We want to hear Trump's opinion on the flag.
Here's one question asked yesterday.
Kelly, to follow up on Peter's question, what
is the president's position?
Does he think NASCAR made a mistake by banning
the Confederate flag?
No, he said he I spoke to him this morning
about this and he said he was not making a
judgment one way or the other.
The intent of the tweet was to stand up for
the men and women of NASCAR and the fans and
those who have gone in this rush to judgment
as the media to call something a hate crime,
when, in fact, the FBI report concluded this
was not an intentional racist act.
And it very much mirrors other times when
there had been a rush to judgment, let's say,
with the Covington Boys or with Jesse Smart.
So she won't answer.
She says, Trump told me, you know, Kaylie,
I'm not making a judgment one way or the other.
Obviously, that didn't happen.
They are making a calculated optics decision
not to say one way or the other.
If you ask me, of course, I just say, yeah,
I'm against the Confederate flag being displayed.
Jonathan Karl from ABC News tries a second
time to get an answer about the flag because
Caylee continues to try to obfuscate and talk
about other things didn't go much better.
Let's drill down on the Confederate flag.
Does she think it was a mistake for NASCAR
to ban?
The president said he wasn't making a judgment
one way or the other.
You're focusing on one word at the very bottom
of a tweet that's completely taken out of
context.
And neglecting the complete rush to judgment
on ratings are down because they banned the
five twenty seven.
And the president was noting the fact that
in aggregate, this notion that NASCAR men
and women who have gone and who are being
demeaned and called racist and being accused
and some venues of committing a hate crime
against an individual.
Those allegations were just dead wrong.
So, again, she won't answer.
And she insists Trump is not judging the Confederate
flag one way or the other.
Well, that's the problem, Kaley.
What we're trying to do is figure out what
is Trump's position on the Confederate flag?
Is Trump actually so desperate, desperate
for the racist vote that he's afraid to denounce
the Confederate flag or play coy, at least
with it?
The answer appears to be yes.
Now, just for reference, this is really interesting
for two reasons.
I found a video of Trump five years ago talking
about the Confederate flag, Confederate monuments.
The video is fascinating for two reasons.
Number one, Trump very clearly says it should
be taken down and put in a museum.
He just says it very clearly, unequivocally.
The other thing that's interesting is Trump
sounds far more articulate and coherent.
Take a look at the video.
You're the lone Republican presidential candidate
who has yet to weigh in on whether or not
you think the Confederate flag should be flying
above the state house in South Carolina.
Do you think it needs to go?
I think it probably does.
And I think they should put it in the museum.
Let it go.
Respect.
Whatever it is that you have to respect, because
it was a point in time and put it in a museum.
But I would take it down.
Yes.
So that is not a Donald Trump who still exists.
No.
One, that Donald Trump doesn't exist in that
Trump is no longer willing to say it should
just be put away in a museum.
It's not doesn't have a place out in public.
The Confederate flag Trump is also not nearly
as lucid and coherent as he was five years
ago.
So Kaley McEneaney now can't say this.
They realize, I guess, that they need the
racist Confederate vote.
But more importantly, I want to mention this
culture war component here.
Here's for me the really important takeaway
from this.
The right loves to accuse the left of fighting
a culture war.
It's Trump who has lost on every substantive
policy issue and now has been relegated to
making the issues of the last two weeks.
Statues and monuments, Confederate ones, Confederate
flags, sports team names, NASCAR and claiming
that he's fighting radical anarchist Marxists
who, of course, don't exist.
That's the Hill.
Apparently they're choosing to to not necessarily
die on, but to plant a flag on, to keep to
use the metaphor.
And that is the culture war.
Right.
I mean, we on the left are talking about corona
virus science, medical policy, public health,
the economy, tax plans, the failures of our
health care system, foreign policy.
They are the ones making it about this.
Now, I know you can say well, but there are
people on the left who are trying to take
down the monuments, OK?
That is not the big issue on the left.
It has been almost exclusively the issue of
Trump for the last 10 days.
Maybe this is an oversimplification, but intangible
issues are easier to claim victory on.
You can't claim that you replaced Obamacare
like you promised because you didn't.
You can't claim victory on the virus, even
though they've sort of been trying to because
people see the numbers would stuff like defending
our monuments and our culture.
I guess you can try to claim victory.
I don't know if
it'll work.